Maybe you missed her calling baseball might've been you find baseball so boring.
It's definitely boring.
It's one of those things that you couldn't and people right now are screaming,
fuck your uh,
your fans hate me anyway.
That's not,
that's definitely not true.
I see it occasionally attention to those comments.
There are music,
there are only the people that would comment something shitty.
They're the only ones that are going to get to you.
Right.
I get it.
There's a lot of Kuk Beta stuff about the kind of,
because they assume I am an open relationship and so therefore there's all that
kind of stuff.
Yeah,
that cut thing.
That's interesting.
Anyone who would call someone else a cook or a Beta male is most likely.
I don't think you could say anyone cause sometimes people just are and some
people say it and they're correct,
but I think for the most part,
but why would you say that you're not in an argument?
Okay.
Like you aren't in an argument with them.
You don't know them.
You guys aren't.
So why are they insulting you?
Why they going Africans?
Because of insecurity.
Let's also,
because of this weird way of expressing each other,
uh,
ourselves on,
on instant,
you know,
on Twitter,
Facebook and stuff,
just to instant that instantaneous ability to just go after something.
You don't meet them,
you don't establish a friendship with them.
You don't talk to them about what I'm saying.
It's a reflection as a psychologist,
I find it really interesting because it's an,
it's,
you know,
you see these guys every fucking day.
There's another story about a,
an anti gay,
you know,
minister who's been sucking little boy's dicks every day,
or even big black guys,
Dick,
whatever,
whatever dixies into.
But if he's trying to like pray the gay away,
yeah,
for sure.
There's some gates going on somewhere.
I think we reveal our deepest secrets in our loudest accusations.
I think you're right.
You know,
and so this whole,
the,
the trolling and stuff going on online is interesting because people don't
realize that they're exposing themselves,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
it's also,
it's a really shitty way of interacting with humans that some people participate
in almost exclusively.
Yeah.
Like there's some people right now in our culture that they're communicating
with people,
but the people that they're communicating with,
their,
their only communicating with people online,
they're only doing it through Twitter or Facebook or however they do it.
So like their days are spent interacting just randomly with people tweeting at
them and reading tweets or reading,
you know,
reading message board posts or posting things or reading Instagram,
passages.
All they're doing is interacting with people online.
And I just think there's a lot of kids developing that way cause there would not
even,
even when they're around each other,
they're spending more time communicating with people through a device than they
are doing it face to face because they're always distracted.
And I feel like this is a very,
it's not indicative of how we evolved like these,
this method of communication.
So like people say there's way more hate today than it's ever been before.
I don't think so.
I think it's the same amount of hate.
There's just this new weird form of expression that doesn't make you take into
consideration the other people's feelings.
It's like the only time we've ever had something like that.
If you killed someone or you beat someone up and you looked at them and they
looked at you and you knew that you hated them,
at least that's an honest attack,
you know?
But if you're,
if you want something terrible to happen to someone and you don't even know
them,
he just heard him on a podcast.
He was a guest and he annoyed Usi want terrible things to happen to them.
Like you're not even,
you don't even know him.
It's like traffic,
anger out.
Fuck you.
Like,
Eh,
you know,
know that guy in that car,
like whatever.
You know where that comes from,
the right traffic.
Anger comes from a heightened sense of awareness because you're going so fast
because you're in your car or scared.
Yeah,
well,
you're ramped up.
You're looking constantly for anything to go wrong.
You can't be at zero and just drive.
When you're driving,
you're very aware that you're at the wheel of a big fucking thing and the car
accidents happen and people die in them.
Everybody's aware of that so you can get,
you get ramped up.